yes joey i did go on a trip oh yeah
where'd you go i went to niigata which
is
northern north yeah it's like directly
north of
yeah japan not japan directly directly
north of japan directly
north of tokyo is what i was trying to
say yeah and i had a
friend kenta from university who
actually loved the story parts from our
university because he was like
correcting some of the details to me oh
really in my mind yeah yeah and how like
the the neo-nazi guy made like
phosphorous chemical substances in the
building
were you yeah were you [ __ ] roommates
with like walter white
honestly this guy was insane man but
anyway yeah
that was it was nice meeting him again i
haven't seen him in ages and he lives in
northern japan and
he's a teacher then a pastor and uh yeah
he's chill
pastor yeah he's a pastor t-o-r not
p-a-s-t
he's a pastor linguine
yeah because in japan there's a this is
kind of so dumb and condescending but
there's a job for like foreigners
because he he doesn't even look that
foreign he still looks japanese he's
half
right he's half while shaft japanese and
um
his job is to basically repeat a script
that a real pastor might
right it's all for show so they just
want a foreign looking guy
to like say something he's not even he's
not even like a legit person no none of
them are
it's like a fake service so you pay a
guy right and he just says the lines and
does all the moves and looks
the whole looks the real part but like
isn't a hester like that's his job
he marries people wait wait how is that
a job what
in in what job sectors needed i think
there's a huge market in japan for like
wanting like a foreign experience
wedding it's like a really like could i
find this on craigslist like looking for
fake news
it's expensive as well he was telling me
the price is like it's premium it's for
like rich people
like rich rich and dumpy to us that's
dumb as [ __ ]
it makes sense right yeah so that's his
job and yeah he's basically like you
want to hang out nigata and i was like
sure i want to leave tokyo i'm just sick
of tokyo
how long were you there for like three
or four days right yeah three days yeah
so the first day i didn't really do oh
the first day i went out with him
at that night and he took me to a bunch
of girl bars
which are not like hostess bars because
hostess bars they sit next to you
yeah it's just like a bar where the
girls are on the other side
oh normally it's like 40 year old 50
year old men just like
right yeah from what i mean from what i
understand it's the
girl bar is just where the bartender or
whoever's like your waitress
is just obligated to talk to you yeah so
we went to like is that right
yeah yeah we went to a bunch though like
a really expensive call center
but it's like just like one on one so
some of the prices weren't bad like the
first one we went into the girls like
only spoke to
the other girls no not that like i'm
like [ __ ] paying me attention yeah i
just i've never been to one he's like do
you want to go to one
and he was like do you want to see them
all and i'm like sure why not this would
be a fun story to tell on trash taste
which is
worth more than money yeah so yeah the
first one was like 900 yen for 30
minutes
so you could drink as much as you want
in that 30 minutes and it went
it went very slowly because the people
were no fun there
but yeah clearly that that explains the
price yeah yeah yeah so we we
just like banter with them like one of
them was saying that they can't
understand english characters and in
japanese i asked them like can you read
kanji and they were like yes and then i
was like i rest my case
i was like wait as they like they can't
read the alphabet they yeah they've been
studying it for like five years and
couldn't read the english alphabet
and i'm like wow i'm like yeah but then
exactly so i was like so you can read
so you can read kanji right in japanese
she's like yes and i'm like
all the old dudes in the bar laugh and
i'm like hell yeah dude and everyone
clapped and stood up now
and then uh he said it boys yeah yeah
yeah
so then we like we left that ball and
immediately like four people were like
yo and i was like oh nice you know these
guys and he's like
no and i'm like oh we're following them
he's like yeah why not
i'm like okay cool right so we're
following them and uh they take us to
a bunny bar oh like everyone's in a
bunny coffee
is that what i think it is everyone's
just saying everyone's just in a bunny
suit yeah but due to covid they weren't
in the bunny suits they're in bunny
school girl outfits
and i thought this is a cop out cause
they're wearing school outfits just but
with the bunny ears
that's like every cosplayer who says
they cosplay and they just wear them
into headbands yeah you know
we walked in there and it was exactly
like what you think it looked like
to quote joey a bunch of ugly bastards
it was like 50 year old men who looked
like
really really like just craving for
attention right yeah
and i looked and we sat down and uh we
looked at the prices and it was like
50 bucks for 30 minutes and then so we
were like
so we're leaving right like we're not
saying here and then he looked at me
like yep
yep all right cool so i'm just gonna go
now and then you follow me yeah so you
just did that
and then the guys didn't look sass right
yeah yeah we ditched the guys who took
us there
and they were like whoa where are you
going are we like nah bye bye
went to another bar that was a lot of
fun we just spent all night and then
somehow
uh some sketchy dude was like come to
another bar i know we don't
never met this guy okay we go there at
what at what time of the night was this
it's like two am okay okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i got taken to
another bar
and we get in there and it's like a drag
queen ball right and like
hell like proper gay ball yeah and it
was a lot of fun and
uh yeah i think sung bohemian rhapsody
and i was butchering it yeah
and i knew the guy next to me was like
you know playing very nice because
he was he was saying i was singing great
and i'm like no no i'm not
i'm like oh real life
yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
who you're with right no one can sing
queen well
yeah everyone butchers queen like you're
a very attractive guy but you don't need
to lie to me
you know what i mean just i know i'm
butchering i know i know i'm [ __ ] at
this
cannot make this more obvious yeah then
we just went to another bar
and just chatted [ __ ] with people i feel
like my japanese got way better when i
was
drinking i don't know why but it's the
same as my japanese
is my thai where when when i get like a
few drinks down me
somehow your language your language
skills just improved by like five folds
i don't know why stop doubting yourself
yeah you just say [ __ ] you just say [ __ ]
really it's really weird though because
like it that works for every language
except
english it's so funny like
i forget how to speak english so yeah
sometimes i just like rant like when i
get super drunk i notice
last time we got drunk in that onsen you
just like started speaking japanese
oh yeah i totally get that because when
i get drunk i just start speaking thai
yeah i'm just like i don't know so many
people have told me like when i get
blind drunk yeah it doesn't matter if
no one around me can speak japanese i
only speak japanese and i'm like
really [ __ ] proficient like i'm i'm
reciting like a [ __ ] like
mlk speech in japanese meanwhile
meanwhile like if i go back to english
i'd just be like more drink here
i just turn caveman when i go english
for some reason i don't know why